découvrez-en icinéma i'm the sky
voici le colonel pau elle elle vous
accompagnera pendant la capture des
niches à l'adie alias susan dan forte
selon nos renseignements il va y avoir
une réunion entre danford et les numéros
3 et 4 de notre liste de personnes
recherchées avec le dernier nos
informations indiquent qu'ils seront
dans cette maison le but de l'opération
est de les capturer et non de l'étude 22
mille pieds iran votre mission est
d'être noreuil dans le ciel à rauzan je
dois savoir si dans une ford est à
l'intérieur et qui est avec elle
ces dates
voilà qui change la donne l'espace on
voit des gilles leblanc général nous
avons la possibilité de frapper il faut
envoyer à une fire à travers ce toit
tout de suite mais s'il est armé
tenu des circonstances je pense que nous
devons annuler
mettez toute la mission en péril à cause
d'un unique dommage collatéral monsieur
le ministre
il me faut une autorisation légale de
frappes je suis le pilote aux commandes
est seul responsable du lancement du
missile
je ne ferai rien tant que la fille était
dans les parages l'enjeu est plus
important que ce que vous voyez sur
votre écran
sais-tu 80 personnes
c'est nous qui remportons la guerre de
propagande si nous tuons ne serait ce
qu'un enfant
ce sont eux qui gagnent
et personne ne veut prendre la
responsabilité d'appuyer sur la gâchette
on a perdu l'image hambourg st il nous
faut une décision presque immédiate
droit à l'aide
attendez 1
i'm the sky le 9 septembre en icinéma
sur vos services de vidéo à la demande
exclusivement chez vous